And greetings to all of you, our friends
and members of the SumTV family. You're
watching I'd Like to Know, SumTV's Bible
question and answer program. I am CA
Murray. I'm flanked to my right by
Pastor Steven Boore. And to my left,
Pastor David Salazar. And we're here to
answer your Bible questions. You send in
the question, we give you the answer
from the word of God. And we make that
promise that each and every answer will
come from the word of God. If an answer
can be found, we will try to find it and
give it to you from the word of God. If
you want to participate, we encourage
you to do so in the strongest possible
terms by writing to tvsumsv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
Gentlemen, we've got a number of
questions. I'm going to ask Pastor Boore
if he would not lead us out in prayer
and then we're going to dive into some
of these questions for today.
>> Let's pray. Father in heaven, we come
before you today with humility of heart.
We know that our knowledge is just so
limited and so we need the help of the
Holy Spirit as we attempt to answer
these questions. So we ask for your
presence through the spirit. give us
clarity of thought, give us clear words
and bless those who are watching the
program that they might be blessed as
well. We pray in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen.
>> Our first question comes to us from
South Africa. Uh the South African Union
in particular. The name is a little
difficult but uh they've given us a
little breakdown of this of how to
pronounce it. It's Cer Lurler. Cerurler.
and thank you for writing the question.
It's a little long, so I'm going to read
it and then uh uh we'll comment on it.
My question is about the role of the
church manual or manuals, books of order
in the Christian church. Are we not in
danger of putting more authority in them
than the Bible and the Holy Spirit's
guidance? Are we not hindering the
reformation which was founded upon the
principle of the Bible and the Bible
alone and teaching for doctrine the
commandments of men as found in Matthew
chapter 15 verses 3-9.
Please guide me through your deep
experience uh in the church and the
knowledge of history. This question is
inspired by a book I once partially read
a few years ago. Uh taking talking about
this topic uh written by uh the Stanish
brothers. Um so that's what they're
worried about as I can digest it. Us
replacing the Bible with church manuals,
working policy, other books of that
nature. How do we line them up one
against the other? I think we need to
start, gentlemen. And I'll release it to
you by saying we are part of that heresy
that says the Bible and the Bible only.
Our working policy and our manual do not
counterict or counterman anything in the
Bible. In fact, they're only legitimate
as they follow the Bible. Right.
>> Uh they were not they were not intended
to be doctrinal papers. They were
intended to be operational guides so
that we're all on the same page.
>> Yeah. So I'll stop there and then toss
it to either of you uh worthy brethren.
>> Well the I think that is important to
remember that the church manual has uh
the purpose of the church manual is to
protect the sound doctrine by aligning
practice with belief. uh also to prevent
the abuse of authority by clearly
outlining limits to promote unity by
giving every church the same operational
standards. Uh it support is supposed to
support the mission by u allowing
pastors and members uh to continue and
to understand what the purposes are of
the church and encourages transparency
in finances discip disciple and
leadership or discipline rather
leadership. So in a sense it's a it's
established to keep order and to allow
the church to be united and at the same
time flexible enough to keep
evangelizing. So it it gives you
operation operating u aspects of how the
church is to to work and how it's
supposed to continue in its intention of
fulfilling the mission of the lord. Um
we have to remember that there was early
on in this history of the Adventist
church some hesitancy of even becoming
organized and white speaks about that uh
there was a need to be organized and
there was a need to be structured. So
it's important to remember that the
structure is not a bad thing. is
actually God is a god of order and it's
important that we keep order and and
have a manual that can reflect that
necessary order um because it gives you
again defines the roles of pastors,
refineses roles of elders, defines the
roles of deacons and members. It gives
you uh ordinances such as how to do
church elections, how to hold church
beatings. Uh clarifies financial
practices, how the tithes work, how
offerings work, how stewardship is to be
made. uh it explains how to handle
membership and disciple and discipline
biblically. So how to work with those
two elements and again helps us to
understand and sets guidelines for
worship and its orders. So there is
these things that are very valuable and
important to keep this structure of the
church going. Um now there are
uh always
policies that are implemented that is
actually by the way they are done only
at a general conference session. So
there is this representation of the ley
that votes in any changes that are need
to be made or rejects changes that are
proposed. So the idea is that is a is a
it's a reflection of a whole of the
church not just leadership or just in
some people and so it helps the church
to have this sense of being part of a
movement and be guided by the people as
a whole. Uh other than that uh there has
been moments in the church that
unfortunately as it always happens in
some cases where there are people who
might use the church manual in a way
that is not intended to be whether or
not is not clear enough. There's
ambiguity about certain things that have
been used against u or or not correctly
applied to the church such as u you know
using the church manual to not allow
guest speakers to come or misusing this
this language that is made there that is
supposed to help churches bring and
allow people to be invited. But we've
seen in certain scenarios where that is
maybe not clearly understood and
sometimes by the influence of a leader
or not or two it can become a problem of
allowing freedom of of a church to be
invite people that is in good standing.
So, we've seen these things and I think
that it's important to keep in mind that
as long as we allowed um you know the
the Holy Spirit to help us understand
what the church manual is and the
policies that are there to help keep the
mission of the church going. I I don't
see I don't see any problem with the you
know church manual. I think it's a
blessing and I think it's something that
needs to be kept. And so, um, I
encourage our our brother here to
remember that we're not putting the
church manual about the Bible. Anybody
that puts that, that's actually doing
the wrong thing. The church, the b the
Bible is our main manual is our
fundamental belief. It's what we
believe. The church is just manual is is
a way to help define roles, to regulate
ordinances, to clarify financial
practices, and to explain how to handle
membership and this discipline
biblically.
>> Yeah. We need to distinguish between the
church manual and the working policy of
the church.
>> Mhm.
>> Um pretty soon the working policy is
going to be an encyclopedia.
>> It is getting
>> for those who are acquainted with it. It
is a massive volume. I up till now I
think it's only one volume but uh
someday might come where it needs to be
more than more than one. Uh the working
policy basically deals with the
day-to-day administration of the church
>> like for example salaries, remuneration,
>> um uh property,
housing,
you know, subsidies and things like
that. Um so, you know, it's not out of
harmony with the Bible certainly to have
policies for a organized operation of
the church.
>> Yeah. Now as far as the church manual is
concerned,
the church manual uh contains only that
which is voted at general conference
sessions.
>> Right. Correct.
>> In other words, uh in order for
something to make it make it into the
church manual.
>> Uh it has to be voted by the full
delegation of the church at a general
conference session.
>> Yeah. Um and um the church manual deals
with for example the functions of
elders, the functions of deacons and so
on. Let me give you an example. In 2010,
the general conference session voted to
allow the ordination of deaconesses
for which I have no objection because u
you know Ellen White says that it's okay
for example to to lay hands on uh on
>> missionary doctors.
>> Yeah.
>> Lay hands on women that serve in the
function of deaconists. So, but but
they're not being ordained as pastors.
They're being in fact they're not even
be ordained.
>> Because Ellen White uh clearly made a
distinction between the word ordained
and the word the expression laying on of
hands.
>> When she talks about deacon, it says
she's talking about the setting aside by
the laying on of hands. and with
physicians that that uh make their
decision to serve in in as a medical
missionary uh set apart by the laying on
of hands. But when it comes to pastors
and elders, she always uses the word
ordination. So there's a distinction
there. Uh why do I bring this up?
Because uh the ordination of deaconistes
is now in the church manual
which means that any church in the world
that wants to ordain deaconistes or set
aside deaconists by the laying on of
hands uh can actually do that and it and
it's global because it was voted at a
general conference session. Another
thing that was voted at at a general
conference session is that only men
should be ordained
uh and receive a ministerial credential.
That's in the church manual. And here's
where we have problems because the
problem is when the church manual is
applied unevenly
where some conferences do what the
church manual says and other conferences
say we don't have to do what the church
manual says. In other words, to pick and
choose which uh which things you want to
apply and which things you don't. For
example, and you brought this up, um the
church manual says that if a church
invites uh someone to speak, and you
brought this issue up,
>> um the the church in consultation with
the conference uh should confirm, you
know, whether that individual uh can
come and preach in the church. Um, the
church manual does not authorize unions
to ban speakers.
It does not authorize divisions to ban
speakers. And yet there are unions and
divisions that ban speakers
>> and that is not in harmony with the
church manual. So my issue is when the
church manual is applied unevenly
>> and it's not applied the way it should
be applied in every case. Uh, for
example, there are conferences that uh
that say if a speaker that has been
invited by a local church does not
believe that women should be ordained,
they're not welcome in this conference.
They're forbidden from coming to the
conference. When that pastor is in
harmony with the vote of the world
church and is in harmony with the church
manual,
>> exactly.
>> That's where things really get sticky.
And um and so I think that uh the manual
needs to be applied evenly.
Only that which is voted at the general
conference session makes it into the
manual. It must harmony harmonize with
the scripture. Obviously
>> for example the church manual uh between
sessions they put in now that Sunday is
the day of rest. This is an exaggeration
right? Sunday's the day of rest. Well we
don't obey the manual
>> because it's contrary to scripture. But
I haven't found anything in the church
manual that is contrary to to what the
Bible says.
>> Yeah. If we lean to the manual over the
Bible, then we would be in danger to do
it. But I want to add another uh work
that uh approved by the church that we
have not mentioned yet, and that's the
minister's manual.
>> Uh the church manual tells us what to
do. The minister's manual tells us how
to do it.
>> Uh the church manual will say you can
you don't want to marry Adventist to
non-adventist. You don't want to marry
two men. You don't want to marry two
women. Right? But once uh you have
gotten permission through the manual to
marry an advent man, an advent woman,
the ministerial manual will tell you how
that ceremony goes out. So the
minister's manual gives you direction as
to how to do it.
>> When we go around the world, and we've
all preached outside of North America,
>> uh there is a consistency
>> to be found around the world. Mhm.
>> That consistency comes really by these
three books, the church manual, the
ministers manual, and the working
policy.
>> Um, so we see a a consistency through
all of them. You both have mentioned
that it the church man can only be
edited, added, subtracted to every five
years at a general conference. But
between the general conferences, that
policy, whatever it is that makes it
into the church manual, has been gone
over by many committees from around the
world. Right?
>> You know, they just didn't pop up at the
general conference. They've been looking
at this thing for five years. They've
gotten into it from all of our divisions
uh and all of those people who sit on
the various committees that go over
these things so that it is in harmony
with the word of God
>> and with the operating policy of the
church. So when you vote something at a
general conference session or you see
something that has been voted at a
general conference session, you can rest
assure that many many consecrated
eyeballs have been on that document. It
has been prayed over and uh it has been
looked at around the world to make sure
that uh it is in harmony with the
working policy of the church and with
the word of God. Um so we we have that
assurance. There's another thing which
is really important and that is that not
even the general conference committee
at annual council or spring meeting can
add to the church manual.
>> Precisely.
>> They they can put on the agenda to take
to the general session
>> something that they want to add to the
manual but they cannot add it to the
manual.
>> Yes. only the church representatives in
session can actually vote something that
is later incorporated into the church
manual.
>> Well said.
>> Uh and that's a very important point.
>> It is a very important point. I've had
the privilege of serving on a general
conference committee and sitting on side
committees where they go out and take
these things and they kind of rip them
apart every you know we spend days and
days and days and days and then we refer
to the general conference session. Um,
if you ever have the privilege of
looking at a a general conference
bulletin and looking at the items that
come up for voting, you see a number of
little ODUP UAP across the top. Those
are all of the committees that that
thing has gone through before it comes
to be voted as a general conference
session. So I don't think we are
gentlemen in any danger of putting the
manual, minister's manual,
general uh working policy or church
manual above the Bible. So the Bible is
our guide but having given that there
must be some nuts and bolts as how we as
to how we operate the church and that's
what the manuals try try to do. Yes, we
we will always uh encourage of course uh
everyone to look into the Bible. Make
sure that you know ask your leaders,
your church leaders to abide by the
Bible and to con, you know, to conform
to the church manual um evenly as you
said pastor, you know, consistently
across the board so that there is
harmony and unity in the church.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I ran across something
sitting on the general committee
conference committee that I did not know
before. There are Robert's rules of
order. They're also general conference
rules of order. They they look almost
the same, but there are some slight
differences as to how we do our policy
as opposed to Robert's rules of order.
So, these are outlined again in the
working policy and the minister's manual
and the the the church manual. So, uh we
can take confidence and and and and take
comfort in the fact that around the
world the church is operating the same
and uh we uh are thankful for that.
Thank you for that question. Uh it may
be a little wonky for some people. We're
a little technical, but there are those
who have these questions and we
certainly want to give time to all of
them.
>> Amen.
>> All right. Um let's see. I'm looking at
our time. We can get this one in. I
think I have been an Adventist for a few
years, but sad to say have not been able
to pay my tithe to the Lord. I want to
tithe. My husband, who is not a
Christian, forbids me to pay tithe. He
controls the money in our household.
Even though we are retired, each of us
receives a social security check every
month. Our incomes are combined and we
pay the bills. I have asked him numerous
times and explained the Bible reasons
for tithing and my desire to tithe. He
is adamant that we can't afford it. I've
been praying about it. I know the Bible
says that a wife is to be submissive to
her husband in all things, but we are
also to obey God rather than man. I feel
stuck between a rock and a hard place. I
would appreciate your opinion or
insights on this issue. I feel I may not
be saved over this issue. It's very
discouraging to me. Thank you for your
time. Uh I prefer to remain anonymous.
So they did they didn't put any uh who
or where they are from and we can
understand that. Gentlemen, what will we
say to her? Uh, we got five minutes and
29 seconds, so we got to do it quickly,
but we need we need to give her some
help.
>> I I think I can I can say a story that
maybe will help her understand what she
needs to do or could do. I met a a woman
who uh became an Adventist, became a
believer in the Bible, the word of God,
and was convicted on the issue of tithe.
And this was in uh this particular case
was in Latin America and there's a lot
of a lot of um
control by a lot of men in their
household just like the the situation
that this woman is sharing. The husband
was you're not going to give no tithe
and you're not going to make you know
any offering to this church blah blah
blah. So uh she was in the same
situation. So she prayed a lot to the
Lord. She kept praying say Lord how do I
convince my husband? how do I let him
understand? And so she started uh
praying and then she started to talk to
him and telling him if you don't give
tithe to the Lord, you're not going to
you're not going to
be blessed by the Lord. The Lord is
going to not give us the blessings he
wants to provide for us. So she was
convicted to share with him that she
needed to give the tithe, that she
wanted to give her tithe and that the
Lord will truly bless that family, that
marriage their prosperity by being
faithful to the Lord in tithing. And if
she he did not do that, she would be
say, "Look, the blessing of God is not
going to be there because we're robbing
the Lord. We're robbing God." And you
know she went through this experience
she said for for several months and and
one day uh she kept insisting you know
we need to get tithe we need to tithe
eventually he said okay I'm going to
give you the tithe and and as when she
received the tithe this was a an
evidence because of of God working in
his heart and eventually he started to
realize how much blessings because every
time she would she would give tithe,
they would have uh uh more more income.
They would have uh just a better
experience in their life, in their home.
So she was trying to always point it to
him that faithful to the faithfulness to
the Lord in these small things would
bring a blessing to them that was even
bigger. uh eventually they are both of
course baptized now and even till this
day they always talk about that
experience as one that helped him
understand that there's a relationship
between providing the faithfulness to
the god and receiving the blessing and
the uh the the multiplication of the
lord in their home by being faithful to
them in tithe and and then they've seen
that in their lives so uh I would
encourage her to talk to him and ask her
ask him to not control and to pro taste
I mean to to prove the Lord to give him
a chance to test the Lord and his
faithfulness in tithe and he will see
the blessing there.
>> Well, there's a principle involved here.
Uh it's found in Acts 5:29.
>> Yeah.
>> But Peter and the other apostles
answered and said, "We ought to obey God
rather than men."
And uh you know that case where the the
husband finally saw the light, there
might be husbands that never see the
light.
>> That's what I see.
>> And then the problem still remains.
>> Uh praise the Lord that in that case it
worked. Uh I I might tell a story that
uh that illustrates this not directly
dealing with tithe. I've told this story
before. Um I taught a girl in Colombia
uh and one day I sat down with her. She
told me her story of how she had come to
the school. um she went to an
evangelistic series in the town that she
lived in and uh she made her decision to
get baptized.
>> And when she told her parents that she
was going to get baptized, they said,
"If you get baptized, uh you're a
Catholic. You should live a Catholic,
die a Catholic, and if you uh decide to
get baptized, you're not our daughter
anymore. You got we're going to throw
you out of the house."
>> So, she had to make a decision. Uh you
know, the Bible says, "Honor your father
and your mother." Yeah.
>> But what happens when father and mother
um overstepped their bounds?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh we have to obey God rather than men.
>> So she decided to get baptized and when
she got home all of her stuff was at the
door and her father said get out and
that's how she ended up at the school.
>> So uh you know
it's coming to the time when we're going
to have to make tough decisions
>> whether to serve God or lose our lives.
Mhm.
>> So if we are not faithful now, no matter
the consequences, we're not preparing
very well for when crunch time comes.
>> Amen.
>> You know, our time is getting away from
us. But I I really want to take some
time to deal with this program. So, I'm
going to do something we rarely do and
that's revisit this program on another
this issue on another program if we can
do that so that we can give because this
is a serious situation and she's kind of
up against the wall and rather than to
rush through this uh we want to give it
>> due diligence. So, we're going to deal
with this on a subsequent program.
Again, thank you for being with us, for
spending your time and sharing your time
with us. May God bless you as you
worship him and serve him. We'll see you
again on another I'd like to know. God
bless you. We'll see you again soon.